foreign
boxed in two minutes for hooking Washington with
the early penalty killing chores in this preseason
action Sutter didn't get it clear didn't get it
through Clegg long drive hit the post up here's
the post and here it comes that's a hard shot
from number 20 for Buffalo lung guy cool it
that can really Shoot the Puppy good stick
there Davies didn't bite on that chain for
Speed by obey cubelle capital is just three shots
in this opening frame to this point with a little
bit more than five minutes separating us from
CIS secure intervention live Bang Bang [Music]
starting the scoring here it is it looks
pretty innocent just working the shot
getting it through Johansen gets it through
and there's that little deck pass by Sutter
right onto the stick in the Wheelhouse of
obey cubelle and notice the goalie he's
reacting look here challenged by Greenway who
makes the takeaway sending it through center
for the youngster Benson two on one developing
Benson right on in and Shepard at the top of
the paint made the stop player and here he
makes a beautiful depth pass the beautiful
Save By the way because of the way the goalie
comes across you notice he's not only compact
I mean he's very he's such an important figure
to the game in Buffalo and they had special
highlights that they've been running for a year
you can go on and on with his memorable calls
that everyone knows snaking his way through
neutral Ryan Johnson four years as a Golden
Gopher with Minnesota and is that a former
Washington Capital Craig Johnson head man
right on in snapshot off the outside of the
post Johansen heading off here's that little
depth passes by Dylan strobe but it's the feat
at the end of the shift excellent step up though
good support day I lapped the air and also iorio
making sure they shut off that half wall and they
did it in a hurry Bryson skips to the middle
feeds for Benson on the rotation play great
stuff Shepard and another Beauty sprawling over
on the rebound Shepard comes up huge here's that
little Play Down Low little one two three there's
the shot Benson starts and Spencer Carberry also
played Derek Joe and the coach for Spencer at the
time in about 2 000 was my blind mate Greg Adams
[Music] it starts with a heavy Fork check good
little Play Down Low a three-way Passion Play
Again guys in the right position to collect the
puck to make sure they're open to get into lanes
and there's the caps with a two-nothing
light washing the Sabers to this point
Matthew Phillips six and zags through Center
picks up speed now with the penalty expiring
snapshot off the inside of the post who's Dolla
brings the iron cleared on by viral this is a
breakaway for turka's in alone but turkey to
his forehand sprawling Stevenson follow-up
chance gonna score from the back side of the
goaltender he's gonna Ricochet off his body
below the goal line Eastern goes right in there's
the puck at one end Zuzu gets a great opportunity
and here come the Buffalo Sabers and here's
paterka watch the right toe and then he banks
it in off the capitals net minder and it's
a 2-1 game here with 402 left in the second
has washed it out in front JJ paterka has
responded for the Sabers it's a 2-1 Advantage with
20 minutes to go in regulation governing Craig
Lachlan up top Al coken's your ringside reporter
the NHL on Monumental Sports Network and all
around the country on the NHL Network today
the capitals lifting the lid on their pre-season
schedule entertaining Detroit here Thursday
Buffalo has a date with Boston on Tuesday at Key
Bank Center this was deflected it just trickled
over top of the cage the capitals don't visit to
Western New York Locker you like this until early
April two games for the caps in Buffalo nine days
apart in April long rest are here to flexion score
the Sabers have tied it Krebs cruising in front
it's great hand-eye coordination they chip it
down low they go back up high in just a little
wrist shot to the net right there and there you
see the hands of Krebs deflecting that puck down
absolutely no chance for the goaltender on that
last play good lateral movement right there by the
Defense Force back by patorca looks like iorio has
fun and every time he hits the ice and every
time he's at the rink he's that type of player
Carabella cruising in snapshot good
can't save by the netminder tokarski
it's this outside for Jost canceled
there by alexio Benson plays it down low
then heads right to the cave Greenway top
side Johnson long range deflection score
Savers grab the lead with 11 minutes to go and
it'll look like Benson cruising in there there
was two guys Benson and Joe's who cruised
in both got a piece of it it looked like
and the goal coming here just an innocent
looking shot once again and there he is
strong pivots through Center Manta one on
one Anthony with a change of pace waiting
for help Off the Bench here it comes from
Milano he fired he scores Sunny Milano
great confidence there with the puck
by Anthony manthick was controlling
the puck he hooks off which pushed
back to D which opened up the lane
but it's all about Milano hustling
From the Bench soft depth pass and
there's the rip that's the catching love
the captive Titus Milano on the board
three on three in the sudden Victory
overtime the caps and Sabers who will
see each other again in this building
in November November 22nd to be specific
Joe's hanging on to it lost it there
Alexei Cronus free and clear protest
in backhand stopped by tokartski a
fine glove save he'll keep it hot
waiting on the perimeter there Bryson
with it five seconds left and like it
or not this game will be settled in the
shootout we were going to a shootout anyway
mulatto against tokarski in the top of the
first Sunny scores top shelf on the forehand
I mean talk about pre-season goals that
is a beauty a highlight reeler we lifted
it up look at the curl and the lift right
under the bar that's bull kulkarski down
he has the upper net available puts it up
over the catching glove JJ peterka looks
to respond German horn Winger against the
chorus of booze he scores he's moving along
the ice between the wickets watch them come
acros it looks like he's going to his back
LaPierre goes way wide carries to his forehand
pad stop tokarski goes snowplow to make the
save I thought he was going to do the same
move that he saw from Milano coming in the
same side here he comes across takes one extra
move to his forehand to try to slide it around
the right pad tokarski had the answer no
stage fright for 18 year old Zach Benson
swooping in slows his Tempo and Stevenson turns
him away it's all about timing for a gold stand
in if he's slow you've got to be slowing your
movement look at him stay with them excellent
textbook footwork by Steve stroll will carry
wide angle in delay and rattle it off the post
shooting back across his body had the goaltender
cleanly beat over that right pad and blocker
Stromer hits the far pipe here he is coming in
and watching shoot across his body right there
that's a hard shot to put in the net hits the
post Brandon byro can win it here for Buffalo
Biro plenty of fakes and he Roots the backhand
to win it for the Sabers he's got a lot of moves
there and that is a lot harder than it looks
going to his backhand on that play and he puts
it under the farm Stevenson watch him come into
the back end look at off the told just about of
the stick that is a deadly looking backhand
to give the Sabers the win here this Sunday